please stay tuned for the rest of the
video but first let's have a word from
today's sponsor the likewise app
likewise is an app for getting
personalized recommendations from movies
tv shows and books based on your
interests you ever open up netflix and
hulu and want to find something new but
you spend like 20 or 30 minutes just
scrolling through looking for something
to watch instead of like
actually watching cut that part out and
use likewise to recommend something to
watch right off the bat and dig into
something new without overthinking it
likewise his recommendations are based
on your shows and movies you list as
your favorites so can use that to find
other stuff similar to your preferences
and recommend things you might also like
let's just say i finished invincible and
want another show like that to watch
because i'm in the mood for some edgy
superhero cartoons
likewise has a list of similar shows and
movies that i can check out instead of
spending forever searching for something
and recommendations like this are daily
so you never run out of things to watch
likewise also features a way to save
lists of all of your favorites so you
never forget the media you enjoy and you
can create groups to join into community
discussions about your favorite movies
and shows so be sure to follow me there
i think one of the best features is that
you can also look up any of your
favorites and immediately get a concise
list of every platform it's currently on
sometimes i just want to watch an old
favorite and i don't want to go through
every streaming service one by one to
find it now likewise can tell me where
to go for it instantly click the link in
the description to download the likewise
app and follow me there it's 100 free so
it's a no-brainer now back to the video
it's been over a year since marvel's
avengers released and communally
disappointed a lot of people by not
really being the game they were looking
for i myself gave the game a more
hopeful and middle of the road review
where i praised the elements i liked
about it mostly the linear levels of the
main campaign and the character
interactions in the story
though guardians of the galaxy came
along and blew this out of the water by
doing all that same stuff better like a
lot of other people i despised the
mission structure bland locations and
generic enemies and frustrating
implementation of paid dlc that took up
the lion's share of this game yet i
desperately wanted to like all of the
parts of this game that weren't live
service related but with time
even that soured the kate bishop dlc
came out and dashed my hopes of things
getting better with time because it just
doubled down on all the aspects of the
game i hated and dumped the ones i liked
it was all massive boring areas of
deserted wasteland full of generic
robots and uninteresting cookie-cutter
mission objectives so i gave up on it i
didn't want to play hawkeye or black
panther because i could already tell
those were going to be more of the same
i predicted that you wouldn't even be
able to go into wakanda just the jungle
surrounding it because you know then
you'd have to have art design and levels
and creative architecture and that's all
too hard it's easier to just copy and
paste trees on a warp terrain and then
put on a dirt or snow or grass texture
and call it a day the only way i knew i
would put any time into this game again
was when they added spider-man because i
love that character and i wanted to see
how they'd handle him and i gotta say
after playing a fair amount of the
spider-man dlc on ps4
i can confidently say this was the final
nail in the coffin i take back every
nice thing i said about marvel's
avengers this game cannot be
saved
according to numerous news sources this
game didn't break even for a profit and
is still struggling to recoup its losses
on the inflated budget after a miserable
launch in the vast majority of its
player base abandoning it shortly after
its release sure the interest spikes up
again a little with each new expansion
and this game does have its die hards
that stick with it despite its flaws but
marvel's avengers is still in the red
for a game of this size and i doubt this
dlc will fix that spider-man is a
playstation exclusive meaning xbox pc
and nintendo 64 players can't access it
which led to them cutting massive
corners out of fairness and having no
story or bosses for spider-man the
entire mission chain is just tasks like
use this attack 20 times complete two of
this type of mission use this other
attack 15 times the best you get in
terms of story is the few tiny dialogue
scenes here and there the longest of
which being his introduction so it
doesn't feel like he just showed up and
no one talked about it you also get some
audio logs
those are
yeah
august 12th
okay not paranoid that guy was
definitely following me
well
following peter but now he's
confused and looking around
everywhere but up
right above you dude
nope nothing
well
at least that probably means he hasn't
seen me change outfits
huh
how long has he been doing this
he spends so much time nervously
stuttering through all of these that i
can read them in about a quarter of the
time it takes him to say them so
maybe just like
don't look at the screen when you listen
to them how the earth's mightiest have
fallen they're so destitute now they
can't even afford to fully render this
opening montage and instead it's one of
those cheap motion comic things you get
in low budget license games all the time
when they have corners to cut biggest
superhero character of all time and the
biggest movie franchise of all time and
they're having to resort to some of the
old chop chop
come on guys i'm talking to my fans
right now
sorry about that
but yeah i've been a little busy and
i've sort of not really kind of been
working with the avengers as a
quote-unquote social media influencer
making spider-man a social media
influencer is by far the cringiest trend
and it's instantly dating itself even
worse than him working at a print
newspaper his voice
isn't the worst i've ever heard and sean
chiplock did a great job with what he
was given don't worry i'm an expert in
hanging out
get it
hanging
well i thought it was funny but the
voice direction seems to have been
sound as nervous and scared as possible
probably because a lot of more
contemporary spider-man media portrays
the character as ultraflanderized oowoo
softboy small bean wattpad fanfic twink
man
it's not tom's fault
it's just every single molecule
surrounding him but unfortunately the
end result is this spider-man sounding
like a combination of robbie damon and
drake bell which
aren't exactly my two favorites
it's too high pitched for a spidey
that's meant to be in college and it
sounds weird coming out of this shredded
buff 90s bod spidey i think pitching it
up was a mistake i'd like to hear sean
chiplock do this character again maybe a
little differently because i feel like
he does have potential well it's a big
part of this game and it's become
synonymous with this character so let's
start by digging into his open closet
full of alternate costumes i took pity
on this financial disaster and decided
to spot them 50 bucks for booze money
after not spending a dime on this game
ever because i got a review code now i
could afford to put all of my avengers
in skins that look halfway decent
instead of the terrible default costumes
and i got myself the old trusty spidey
armor as well as the secret war suit i
think this being so prominent in every
video game for the past 10 years has
been kind of ironic because its original
appearance in the comics is limited to
these two panels
this is the most you ever see of it just
that just a hand in this one that and
the concept art in the back of the book
and like an unused cover and that
somehow got a full skin but not the big
time or future foundation suits they
just recolored the bulletproof suit and
there's no black costume how easily you
were showed up by fortnite of all things
the noir suit is somehow
not available just recolors of it that
look like crap
i think i have to wait for it to be
added to the shop which is
maddening but hey at least it's the
first time this has ever actually had a
trench coat they had cape physics
already nailed down because of thor so
they could just slap it on i guess and
the rest of these look like bootleg
rainbow colored [ __ ] these are worse
than what i predicted the suits would be
like they have costumes that have
mustard yellow sky blue and gold all
mixed together or like
purple and orange masks that no one
would ever want and of course they put
in webman you're pathetically
predictable what the hell were they
thinking with this design of the parker
industry suit they connected the eyes in
the middle you have your mother's eyes
and they were always too
[ __ ] close together so take the
handful of good cosmetics and throw the
rest in the trash it's good to know
having zero faith in this game's level
of restraint paid off i will admit
however that this default costume you
get at the very start is the most scrum
diddly-umptious fantasma astical
spider-man suit i've seen in years it
has nice materials the seams are in
sensible places the webs look neat and
clean and visible at a distance and the
colors are really nice and it's cool to
have a relatively buff spidey in
something after he's been portrayed as
more stringy and thin and recent stuff i
love this costume i wish this is what
the movie costumes look like
and then to contrast we have this
atrocity it's like every bad spider-man
redesigned ever lumped into one costume
panel lining on the blue parts that
serves no purpose chunky black lines
bordering the shoulders and everything
else segmenting the red in ridiculous
ways that don't make sense and hideous
logos on the front and back that for
some reason remind me of the mega bloks
logo i can't explain it wanna hear me
rag on this for a few more minutes
here's a time code to skip that i have
pages and pages of material everyone's
talking about the war on christmas i
want to talk about the war on
spider-man's [ __ ] sleeves almost
every time we've seen them for the last
decade they've been segmented with black
or blue lines or omitted entirely
there's an argument to be made about
modernizing superhero costumes like
taking the trunks off batman or superman
but why is this completely benign design
element recently accrued such vitriolic
[ __ ] ire and hatred from every
concept artist from here to timbuktu
every goofy [ __ ] with an art degree
in a drawing tablet thinks they're
completely reinventing the wheel by
slicing up this part of the suit like
it's a bold new choice that's never been
done before and then proceed to jerk
themselves off with their newly minted
overwhelmingly blue abomination as the
checks from sony and marvel roll in
what's the reasoning is it because the
webs on his biceps are hard to draw when
he bends his elbows and everyone's
gotten lazy
bunch of [ __ ] hashtag restore
spider-man sleeves why would you remove
the belt if you were going to just put
big lines on it to imply where the belt
should be
doesn't that like
contradict the whole point of removing
it all you're doing is drawing attention
to the fact that it's not there but
having it cut this way it looks like the
red part starts too far up his belly and
it gives the impression the suit doesn't
fit properly your big idea on how to
reinvent the most iconic superhero
costume was to make it seem like he was
too tall for it i swear to god they
really thought about giving him toe
shoes the thought occurred to them in
the process i just know it it was the
only thing they had the sense not to go
through with [ __ ] this thing how easily
you were showed up by fortnite of all
things
so anyway let's talk about the gameplay
the combat feels about the same as any
other character in this game with your
strong and light attacks and your
constant button mashing and occasional
dodge his moves are very reminiscent of
how he fights with the insomniac games
with very similar animations but they're
still relegated to the same two buttons
instead of a more specific command
so doing these moves doesn't feel as
satisfying and deliberate even if the
combat looks about the same visually as
the better spider-man well
it looks the same but like
60 percent slower
dollar store ass spider-man swinging
isn't terrible but it's not really great
either you can't influence your
direction too much while in mid-swing so
it's damn near impossible to swing
around a corner fluidly and you have to
readjust yourself between swings instead
it's very slow and heavy feeling and has
a set height limit in the game's maps
with webs that don't connect to anything
they don't even just go all the way into
the sky you can see them actually
attached to
nothing ironically swinging in the city
or in a tight corridor is less fun than
just an open field with nothing around
you for miles at least here you don't
slam into something constantly and you
can start to pick up a little speed but
when you're anywhere else it's just too
unruly to get movement with nuance it's
just
underwhelming and not really fun or
dynamic how easily you were showed up by
fortnite of all things for something
called impact webbing this sure feels
[ __ ] limp playing multiplayer is once
again fun not because the game is fun
but it's fun hanging out with people i
like
the game is just something to keep your
hands busy i might as well be playing
with a [ __ ] rubik's cube or i could
just build a lego set and then rip it
apart piece by piece and then build it
again to simulate playing this game
again again i love repetition in the
time since i've played avengers last i
got into fortnite because of that alien
and predator dlc and i now have a frame
of reference of how a competent live
service game works it has frequent
updates and new content the micro
transactions aren't overwhelming and you
can still have fun with the game without
spending money on it and the progression
through the battle pass is simple and
understandable the tasks to gain
experience points are easy to grasp and
you can just jump in and do them every
round the level 100 unlock every season
seems like something actually achievable
that you can get if you just play a
little bit every day which keeps you
coming back in avengers progression is
an obvious skate it's slogged with
confusing challenge instructions
challenges that take way too long to
complete for not nearly enough reward
and gameplay that's stiff and repetitive
i want to put this game down forever 30
minutes after turning it on every single
time in fact this game makes me sleepy
every time i tried playing it for this
video i just wanted to stop and go lay
down
squares avengers as a secret government
opt to pump melatonin waves through your
ethernet cord directly into your brain
so you're too sleepy to realize how
terrible everything's gotten outside of
your home this just isn't how you design
fun progression every task is tedious
and takes forever the challenge card
keeps throwing terminology at me for
certain attacks i need to do on enemies
but it never explains what the hell each
one is
there's dozens of different moves with
different names and i have to go digging
around in the four pages of skill trees
to figure out which one i'm being asked
to do only to find out it's a move i
haven't unlocked yet and have to grind
for hours to obtain just so i can even
start a percentage of that daily
challenge and then on top of that it's
the mission chain that does pretty much
the same thing i have to defeat high
value targets from aim three times well
i'll be damned if i can figure out who
they're talking about without just
googling it and seeing where they spawn
okay so
just enemies with the skulls above their
heads why not mark a place on the map
where those enemies spawn for me so i
don't have to go guess where they are or
look up the answer make it easy on me if
you're not going to make it fun i think
the reason this game failed is because
it's just so inaccessible you have to
spend so much time learning how to
navigate these menus and what everything
means and how it wants you to progress
you can't just pick it up and play and
that's incredibly alienating for some
people maybe they're so desperate for
cash the idea is to make the gameplay so
boring and tedious that you just cave in
and buy levels on the challenge card
with real money to skip all the [ __ ]
and get the rewards which makes sense
until you realize you'd be spending
money to get cosmetics for use in a
gameplay that you hate because it's
boring oh wow i sure do look awesome in
this skin doing the same capture of the
point task in the same four warehouses
over and over fighting the same generic
robots for the millionth time you want
to swing through new york as spider-man
well there's already a game for that all
you get is the same five forests on
shuffle oh this one has snow in it [ __ ]
you
[Music]
the mission chain is boring and tedious
to the point that i don't see any real
advantage in finishing it they don't
have any bosses for spider-man to fight
but they do name-drop mark raxton a
bunch of times and have him appear in
one tiny dialogue scene at the end just
so he could not be molten man
so like
what's the point of all that even why am
i playing this i was starting up the
spider-man mission chain with my sister
and my fiance both watching me and i was
like kind of bragging and joking and i
said hey can you believe how weird my
job is i'm technically working right now
my little sister looked at the screen
and dead ass just said yeah this
definitely feels like work and she's
right this sucks i'm not having fun
playing this feels like a chore i don't
want to beat it just so i can say i beat
it and the reward is a costume that i
clearly don't like so why bother they
didn't put any real effort making this
dlc fun so why should i play it i like
spider-man sure but not enough to be
bored for hours and hours on end for
some stupid sense of completionism if
they're not going to try then neither am
i i'm done with marvel's avengers and
you should be too
[Music]
don't spend money on this not even for
spidey just go buy guardians of the
galaxy instead because it's a much more
entertaining polished and passionate
product
you can see love in that game marvel's
avengers doesn't love the source
material it doesn't love its player base
because it lies to them and then rolls
it back when called out for it
[Music]
this game only loves the almighty dollar
and it's not even going to put in the
effort to earn that money vote with your
wallet if you don't want games like this
being made anymore then don't play it
just a hate on it for your youtube
channel like a jackass just avoid it
entirely avengers deserves a hell of a
lot better of an experience than
whatever this offers what a boring
depressing nightmare
[Music]
[Music]
you